you have a duty to be skeptical as a
journalist that is your job I've learned
a lesson in the pandemic about that
definitely definitely and I would
totally accept that I think I was too
strident anyway got two kind of wrapped
up in it all but you know I had good
reasons for it you're one of my
colleagues at Good Morning Britain Kate
garraway her husband was in a coma from
covid I have four or five friends and
family who lost loved ones how to say
goodbye to the parents on FaceTime and
Care Homes where they ripped through and
so on so I was very like emotionally
invested in it probably too much so for
a journalist like I accept that